okay hello everyone this is my third
live stream of today um we are going to
do some discussion about software design
uh this is uh incremental language
development meeting
talking about future versions of wolfram
language and features
to include in them
all right we've got a collection of
different topics here the first one
converting strings to numbers
um
so this is a discussion we had
internally um
a couple of weeks ago about what is the
best way to turn a arbitrary string
that is a number into
that number as an expression
and right now we have a half dozen
different ways to do that some of which
are documented some of which aren't and
all of which have some drawbacks
okay so we've got a number like this
8.678
and if i say something like two
expression of this
i'm not confident you know it i don't
want it if that thing had a i had a cue
in it or something i want it to fail
right that's is that the basic issue
yeah so our our best documented and most
robust version of this is interpreter
but the downside is interpreter is also
the slowest form of doing this well why
don't we speed up that case
so that's
one potential solution here is to
improve the performance and interpreter
there are also
a number of different complications in
the the low-lying
the low-level functions we have like
string to manager and string to m real
are very fast but they have issues with
either overflowing or handling certain
inputs
right it's obviously easy to make some
okay so the question is should we have a
separate
string to number
function
right the a to i or something or or
something of of um
um
what will we call i mean so this is the
analog
i mean we have integer string
which turns
you know a number into a string right
i mean we also have
if i say
integer string comma
armenian let's say
i'm going to get
wow
that's because some of these only
support very low numbers right yeah
by the way is that a correct message
is it the algorithms or is it the
definition of this for armenian
the problem is that we have we don't
know in all the cases if it's the
algorithm or the definition why don't we
why don't we have somebody curate those
things
it just seems like something we should
know
that's what i'm saying
i mean
it's a once and for all just a once and
for all thing but we we just look up
what you know what is the maximum size
of numbers supported by each kind of
algorithm i mean each kind of each kind
of number system because i mean there
may be ones where you know somebody
invented some wacky extra symbol for 10
million or something
but nobody uses it and we can decide we
don't have it therefore we're not going
to um
um
you know you know what i'm saying
right some are
modern extensions actually and not
actually use it on the time let's say
i mean
yeah okay but all right but that's not
really relevant to this discussion this
discussion is about
i mean
you know it's basically a two-number
thing yeah the so the root question is
do we want to focus on
interpreter as the direction we steer
everyone and just say interpreter needs
no i think we want a two-number function
i think that's a useful thing to have i
think it makes sense we've got two
string to expression
why not two number i mean arguably we
should have had this
you know 35 years ago it would have been
obvious to build it then and we didn't
build it then because we thought we
didn't need it
um
and will be needed something like to
number integer versus real
well yeah i mean i think
i mean are you proposing that we have
two just like we have random real random
integer
we could say two integer and two real
are there gonna be many ambiguous cases
where you
would want either one
[Music]
well yeah i mean and i mean
yeah i mean the issue is
you know in the two-number case of this
right
to real it's
presumably by default machine precision
right
so this is connected to something that
is important in a round which is that
you may have point zero and point zero
zero with strings do we care about that
so around us care about that so around
try a real
in a string inside the round
and a string
yes
three point yeah exactly
wow that's really cool
so the strings can contain information
that we don't have
naturally wow
real will be something like around
without the precision done right
well it wouldn't have the precision so
it would fall back to
you know
number the number of that around object
i'm sorry
write the string i mean bracket number
after the round
so that's now a number that is stacked
with the position
but what precision does it actually have
i mean does it have machine precision or
lower precision lower precision because
you started with four zeros only
i see
so it's an arbitrary position number
basically
right
whereas if i do something like this
ah
okay i'll i'll i don't know why i lost
to zero there
but if i do this i'll get that
um
yes that's missing 0 is a small thing
that we have discussed in other places
but
it's reported
i think it should happen
okay
but the question is here
you know two numbers
i mean
let me give another example
this whole business
oops that's all i meant
that's another kind of what is the
okay so that at this point how do you
get that programmatically
from digits
oh yeah right
but that's not it's not the same thing
because that's a string how do i get it
as a string
if i have the string five six e f how do
i get
into your string
no
no that's the other way around
no that's that i want to go from five
six ef
to the number
from digits you can use from digit comma
16.
oh yeah
no but
wait a minute
i'm confused from digits does from
digits work on strings
i don't think so it does yeah it does
so this function that we're now talking
about what does from digits do
if i give it a decimal point
from digits doesn't work with reals or
negative values is
two two of the big issues
right that's why i think maybe having a
proper function that could will take all
the good things of all the functions
that are in the left
will be great
well arguably we should i mean there's
no reason why from digits shouldn't be
interpreted shouldn't be faster from
digits shouldn't handle these cases
i mean maybe this case is too weird
all right but i agree that we should
have these functions and i i kind of
think
that we might as well just have all
three of them
are making sense
but should they need to be clear from
the string whether it's an integer or a
real
not always
i mean
in the case two
you could want that as a real yeah so it
would coerce if you put it in too real
come back as a real value to that error
and i mean two real would then have a
string
and then presumably well it needs two
other things
it needs to know the base to assume and
the precision
right and there's no choice but to have
let's see what's an analogy to this um
integer digits
takes the base and then the precision
so i think this should be the same thing
shouldn't it
that makes sense
okay
because most of the time okay so in this
case it's a string and it's a base
for two integer
now
arguably we should be able to have a
third argument
that deals with you know
weird kinds of integers like armenian
integers
what happens if i feed that into
interpreter
that is a good question
um
yeah
okay do we have any capability to pass
these things
we do don't we
is there something in icu francisco i
haven't
checked that okay
okay so right now we do not believe we
have any function that parses these
only for roman we can pass them with
from digits
right
but do we how do you describe that from
digits you say roman instead of instead
of the base right yes
i think we have dedicated functions for
romans
now we have them also
right
well it seems to me this would be a
useful capability to have
and what are the functions so this from
roman numerals permit
roman numeral
that is going to roman numerals
and there's also
from roman numeral
well this is what i think we should have
two integer two real and two number
two number also presumably taking up to
three arguments and i guess if you try
and give a precision argument and i
think so and i think it could even take
even more arguments if it has
um i mean in modern with our modern
design methodologies
in a sense it would be something like
this
armenian arrow
uh
you know
that thing there
i don't know that's the right way to do
it
or alternatively i don't know whether
those things have decimal forms well two
integer
actually come to think about it we don't
get to have both the base and and from
digits has already got the the um
uh you know the the precedent of having
that be like that
so i'm saying because from digits
already had the the ability to have
roman there
integer string mixes them too
okay
and is interesting
it can be a base or a name named system
okay
i see okay fine well then then this is i
think the way to do it
okay
makes sense to me
and then i think we should just make
interpreter call these functions when it
is given the appropriate thing okay
let's talk about
okay negative numbers are pretty obvious
um
well for integers it's clear we should
just have a large number if it needs a
large number
yeah i think these are mostly just
examples of the current options we have
and how they behave
okay
e notation okay i think we should
support e notation yeah so that's one of
the cases that two expression fails on
because obviously with the rotation it's
trying to multiply it
right so that's a good reason to have
this
right but the internal functions we have
of string two and real works fine so
okay
okay
well i mean and you know clearly it can
decide if it has a large value by just
counting the number of digits on the
string and then a number of characters
in the string
and then do something fancier in those
cases
that make sense
do we need any of the number form
options here like ways to control the
decimal point and things like that
um
no because oh you mean you mean because
they could be using a comma decimal
point
exactly
yes we should have that
in fact we should have
we'll do that
okay so look if they give a number like
this
it should work
unless you tell it that the decimal
point is a comma that should decomify
the number
that's 56 553 not 56.553
exactly yeah
i mean we should do the obvious
courtesies
um
which you know we can pre-scan very
quickly to find out is there anything in
there other than the digits
and then we should deal with that case
and clearly for integers we should do
the obvious thing for those
and um
i mean i don't know whether we should
generate an error if there are commas
but the commas are in weird places
that make sense
there's different digit blocks like i
know
in different countries you may have
three digit blocks or four digit blocks
with commas depending yeah no no i mean
is there a local option that we could
have for these things
yes
yes and i say
i think they can even pass the armenian
now we were looking at the library
okay but i'm asking the question for
things like digit block behavior
we can take a look if there is also
something to handle that yeah
okay
i have the impression that in when it
comes to interpreting numbers it's
usually important and so it's better to
error out rather than to be very
flexible and interpret things that
are inappropriate
sorry i spaced out for a second could
you say that again please yes i was
thinking of a similar situation we have
when when passing data strings that we
are so flexible that we typically end up
interpreting things that are not dates
so here i would tend to error out when
there are unclear things rather than the
inflexible screen
yeah
parsing numbers is important yeah
particularly we want it to be fast so we
don't want a huge array of heuristics
interpreter can fall back to that but
the baseline function fine then then we
should just fail if
maybe we can have a digit block you know
we could have progressively we can add
in options to two integer that are the
inverse of the number form options
yeah
okay be good to inventory all those
writing instead of guessing it would be
better that the user actually specifies
this is the format i'm feeding to this
function
except some i think we should allow by
default
well
maybe we shouldn't maybe we shouldn't
even know the commas and the numbers by
default
well only if you specify that as a
number
as decimal
number point yep well no i'm saying not
number point i'm saying just a digit
block separator
what i'm saying that that that number
just you know we can think of that just
having a a digit block separator 56 000
whatever
making sense francisco okay so that does
that just fine yeah interpreter already
works with all these cases
okay well the question of whether we
should allow digit blocks
like this
in two integer is not obvious to me
i kind of think we should
by default what that means is we have a
default digit block
uh because i mean digit block normally
on output it would generate that digit
block but an input is it saying you have
to have that digit blocking
or what
i don't understand that so this is a
this is a function with only input in
strings no if it's mandatory to have
that digit block that's a question right
so the analog and date string parsing is
that we usually have
delimiters possible delimiters so white
space or commas or slashes depending so
there may be some obviously when you're
generating in a number form you know
explicitly what you're inserting but
when you're parsing
it's generally somewhat helpful to have
either digit blocks or separators
presented as a list
and these are possible
separators if we're trying to do
something a little more heuristic
right
so that we can do a string delete of
these separators and that's it right for
the digit blocks
so if they are not there that's fine
anyway
what is this ethan is commenting on a
live stream about readable time string
oh those things yeah yeah yeah
what are we doing about these
what is this
it's kind of like texturing a quantity
but i think it chooses a reasonable
unit automatically
for assuming it's seconds
maybe it's like texture
of seconds
yeah okay okay the issue is it's just
like n can print a number at a certain
precision
this is printing a time string with a
certain default unit
that is a human appropriate unit
right
which is something we could do a lot
better in a lot of places
by making sense so if i say something
like
um
you know quantity
uh let's say 10 to the six
seconds
right what is that i mean okay so if i
say
unit convert
i was going to say unit simplify
we'll
rescale that
it's irrational that's not
there's uh seconds to quantity in the
function repo that does something
similar too
i didn't even remember about units by
the way this this business about getting
out things like this in rationals is
crazy
um i tend to disagree so for us it's
always very important that we give exact
results okay exactness
sorry i was thinking that there are two
mixed problems here one is nice reading
and another one is how much
approximation you allow
yes
yeah but i mean you know normally
for time for most
quantities
by the way what if i don't even know how
this works if i do units simplify
of
um
[Music]
10 000 meters let's say
oh that's nice
when did we put unit simplify in i could
have used this a zillion times we
put it in initially in version 9 i
believe but we've been making some
tweaks to it to do
[Music]
more things like this
so embarrassed that i didn't i i could
have used this function a zillion times
i'm i'm just horrified
okay
yeah the original version was a little
less robust it was you know it was
convenient for taking something like si
base units and turning them into
whatever
side of the unit you have for or
rescaling but
probably
we talked about possibly having units
simplify
give a mix radix time value back because
times particularly complicated because
yes you know we have irregular
intervals to measure so instead of 1.6
weeks it could be one week four days and
absolutely yeah right
so
something else we recently added which
is also convenient here is that if you
go to the original quantity a million
seconds and you do unit convert of mixed
unix
what is it nick it's it's like dms or
something like that uh
hm
dhms
i believe so yeah
so we have created some
short hands
so that and that's mixed unit
not a mixed unit
the symbol mix unit and and inside
rather than a list
yeah just capital d capital h capital m
capital s
hms
yeah it does need to go
no autocomplete yeah it has been added
very recently
you mean like
well apart from the disgusting spacing
problems this is cool yeah
yeah because what we had before is the
least days hours minute seconds which is
very long so this is just a shorthand
right
by the way we should do something about
these spacing problems i don't know
what's causing them but they seem to
happen you see what i'm saying that the
yeah
can
this is a separate thing to go debug
okay
okay
um
by the way stan is love on our live
stream comments that java allows
underscores as digit separators
so i don't know what we've i mean
arguably
we should have some version of this
which is very permissive about those
things
but i mean if you say digit separator 0
underscore then you would deal with that
with a sort of inverse number form
approach
yeah
okay is there more to say about this for
the time being no i think that pretty
much covers it i think we generally
agree that having dedicated functions
makes sense and then fixing everything
else to work faster
also makes sense
this is a related topic it was a
somewhat popular function repository
function that
gives back
short ordinal number strings we already
have
spelled out ordinal numbers in integer
name and basically wanted to see
if this is useful enough to also add the
integer name either as ordinal short or
something like that
uh i would think so
for integer name
for integer name specifically i don't i
don't know whether there's a convention
for where
when we when we're using digital is sort
of digitized numbers but that's a silly
word um
versus
spelled out numbers
yeah i mean i don't know if there's
going to be a hard cut off for for
switching between them um but i figured
if we add a ordinal short or
some other name for i know i know i know
i'm just wondering about the name yeah
i just don't know what our naming
conventions are let me look it up for
for integer name for example
whether short is the right
term
like ordinal digits or something
right i'm guessing now i'm thinking
about the names in date string which is
the first thing i thought of too
where there's lots of shorts
yeah i mean there's the words version
it could be it's ordinal then
an analogy to these these sports versus
words
yes it would be
yeah i think digit's ordinal would be
the right
or ordinal
what does cardinal do
uh so so the
this comes from the fact that in many
languages the
is actually the
spell out adjective of the number
oh so how do i see this which what
language does
does this
so for example in
for the number one in
in spanish the cardinal it's different
for feminine and masculine
oh gosh
um
okay so also for german for
in a list
yeah okay
well can i i presumably can just say
language arab spanish
okay and then what i would say here
is i could say i don't know who gets the
default but let's assume it's that
[Music]
ah okay
okay um
and also for the for this short ordinal
we will need also the gender by the way
in many languages
and that's supported by the libraries we
have so
we can implement that
okay well so okay so the only question
then is what the name for it should be
and i kind of favor ordinal digits
digits ordinal
okay most consistent is probably digits
ordinal do you agree
yeah i think that's consistent with our
naming convention for the function
and there isn't a need for digits
cardinal is there because there's no
cardinal tagging the cardinal is the
default form
is that right in all languages
in most languages i think it's the
default yeah
yeah cardinal is a default for for the
words actually in most cases
okay well we should check that there's
no case where that isn't the case
francisco how do you get uno in spanish
for example rather
than let me check that
what does that mean
well
for us
the number is called uno the counting
when you say akar it will be
um
so we have uno and
what you got there is
which is an adjectival form of the
number basically exactly exactly but
itself
with words yep sorry that's words
actually words is the spell out and yes
cardinal is the adjective form
so so you can get uno if you change
cardinal by words in the
input
28
so what's that okay
so that's actually there so cardinal is
actually not a default yes you're right
no remove the karna
so so that's the
right so that's the name of the number
and that's true for most uh languages
actually
at least latin languages and
[Music]
german etc
they have also this difference
okay so
reviewing this again
there are
potentially cardinal digit cases yes or
no
there's ordinal digit cases we know 2 2
nd for example
22nd
but the cardinal for 22
is
in english it's just 22. but is that
true in all languages or do some
languages have a marker for the fact
that it's a cardinal number as opposed
to an adjectival number for example
right the difference between is the
spell out which will be the name of the
number versus the cardinal form which is
the adjective no i i know but i'm saying
in english for example
the ordinal form has a marker like nd at
the end of 22 for example 22 the digits
2 2.
so i'm saying the ordinal has that
marker
then the three forms we're talking about
for these numbers the adjectival form
which is 22 cars
the
number the naked number 22
generated by some number theory
computation
the abstract number
and then the 22nd car
ordinal case
right
i understand the question but i don't
know the answer
in spanish certainly it's the case that
our cardinal digits is the number itself
okay but i i can't imagine that that
would always generically be true
and
well i think maybe nick knows more about
that for example in japanese you have
the counting number so that would be the
cardinal form of the yeah i mean
japanese is a hard case because there's
four dozen different counting values you
have a different word for
n cars than n dogs than end bottles why
why
it's
it's partly historical i mean you
so the the counting form changes a bit
because of
the
it's not necessarily morphology but it's
the in in japanese there's very few
vowel sounds and so as words smoosh
together
often pronunciation or the the words
themselves will change a small bit
um
so
so okay so it's not the nature of it's
the sound of the word for computer not
the nature of computers as opposed to
chickens or something
i i think that's the case actually so i
think there are languages in which
every object belongs to some sort of
meaning
meaning family and the counting
the words you use for counting depends
on the meaning family
there's a
particular type of set of counting words
you used for machines for example there
would be another one for
chickens that would be women and which
language japanese yeah and japanese
generic would be hitotsuhutatsu
mitsu and then you might have ipiki
nihiki sambiki for computers or cars
the characters are the same but the
pronunciation is totally different
oh gosh okay it's a complicatedness the
characters are the same so we care about
the characters yes
but not always the same right
the
the characters for the numbers
themselves are the same but there's
usually an accompanying character that
indicates what type of thing you're
counting so it's not unique for
everything like computers use the same
counting
marker as animals but they're different
than bottles or generic machines
and
[Music]
i mean here's a question so so just in
terms of language understanding so one
possibility is it's like having genders
or something
and it's a generalization of that
another possibility would be like in
latin for example where there are just
different declensions and so far as i
know i maybe i'm wrong about this
words are sort of randomly assigned to
different declensions
i never thought about that actually i
mean whether there's a rhyme or reason
to whether something is a third
declension
latin word or a first declension latin
word
i don't think there is but
that would be a you know
a chicken might be in one declension and
a giraffe might i don't know what they
know about giraffes what in another
declension
yeah my guess would probably be that you
know knowing linguistics there's
probably some rhyme or reason to it but
it's often buried far enough in
language history that it's
basically obtuse to
any actual language speaker
right
okay but so so you're saying in japanese
if i give you a different category of
thing like
moon moons of planets could you tell me
immediately what its
costs in terms of
number descriptors would be
yeah generally they are
categorical based on the type of
noun you're describing but there are
okay but so i'll give you a i mean
i've invented a thing let's say um
i don't know
uh
you know branch pairs in a
multi-way system which has never been
seen before
how would you know which class to put
that in it would probably go into
generic counting
units so the generic
you know
one two three equivalents but for
example there's a counter associated
with cylindrical objects so bottles of
coke oh gosh
you know extruded cylinders are are one
counting class and animals are another
one but some machines also count like
animals
i i'm a little rusty on the exact
categorization for everything but how
many categories are there roughly
probably
20 to probably more like 50 if you count
into more obscure things that are not
okay so just like we have feminine and
masculine in principle there will be a
category 6
type of object
yeah i
i haven't looked enough into the
computational linguistic side of
japanese to know if there are category
classes enumerated but
i'm sure
but probably there are some lists of
these kind of things but i'm not sure if
that should be part of this uh
function no i mean it's hopeless to make
that but i'm just asking my question is
okay we expect cardinal to be the
spelled out cardinal thing but there
might be a cardinal digits which in the
case of english
would be simply the um
the integer string basically yeah yeah
that seems reasonable to me i mean so is
it ordinal digits or digits or no
that's what we need to decide here but
okay well i mean i think
it should be digits words
i think digits ordinal is okay
yeah i think it's the most consistent
with the existing names and it's fairly
clear
dodge is commenting on a live stream but
in polish apparently
there is
oh that's a distinction in ordinal and
the number name yeah that exists in most
languages
the issue is whether there's a
distinction between the number
and the cardinal
number name
right anyway
um
okay
yes and besides karina and ordinance
there are other cases that we are we
have not yet implemented because they
are using a few languages like native
locative vocative et cetera all these
things oh gosh yes
yes yes
the
yes
how do the numbers
wind up in cases
i mean i thought
as adjectives so so they they have to
inflict like they
know how many languages
great okay well
so maybe we can check if we can add them
or not and report right
i mean the whole inflections project i
don't know what the state of the whole
inflections project is words in general
is that in your area francisco
could be i i haven't been in that
conversation
okay fine
i mean it's something we've been
discussing for several years
and alan i thought had said that that
was now an active project again of
getting curating all the inflections for
words
let's say even in english
um you know jump jumping jumped
jumpable whatever
okay all right are we done with this
topic yep i think we're clear um we
might skip over this one because
constantine isn't with us or we can look
at those um
so
this is a topic um
specifically related to how we handle
irregularities in date arithmetic
um
the basic gist is there's
two ways to think about adding a month
to a day
it can either be incrementing the
calendar by one month and we
jump over to whatever that is or it can
be using a fixed definition that a month
is
365 over 12 days i get it so basically
if i say february 28 plus one no
actually let me give you a better
example january 30th plus one month
where do i land
yep and the answer is it could
there are generally four possible
results one is to just use a fixed
definition of a month as it is n number
of seconds regardless of where you
started
so that will rarely be useful
right for month it is generally not
useful
these gaps apply both to
months on a gregorian calendar but also
on other calendars it gets more
complicated it applies to time zone
transitions because
what if i'm adding a day
to
november
[Music]
7th at midnight am i moving 24 hours
later or 25 hours later because there's
an extra day or an extra hour during the
daylight savings transition
or
when we get down to the microscopic
level with leap seconds if we're adding
in a leap second
and i want to add an hour am i moving
ahead an hour on the clock or am i
moving ahead
3 600 seconds
so yeah i get it
right basically there's two large
classes one is simple in that it is
always using fixed arithmetic all units
have an exact definition and we just
move that far
along the time scale
and the second case that is generally
more common is using
constructed arithmetic or calendar
arithmetic where we are
moving or incrementing a calendar step
and within that constructed arithmetic
there are basically three different ways
of handling
complicated gaps so your case of january
30th plus a month is supposed to be
february 30th what do we do there
there are three rolling methods here you
can either roll forward which means go
to the next existing date if we land on
a gap roll backward go to the last
existing date or roll over where we
continue counting from the last existing
date so that section if other people
address this issue or not
um so there are
other other people have in
different sets of software um
sometimes they'll have a dedicated
rolling function
for saying you know i want to i want to
roll this date back or i want to
you know add to the i want to go to the
end of the month regardless of where
that is
um what we are looking at proposing is
having basically a method option in the
date arithmetic functions that say what
you want to do do you want to use fixed
unit definitions
or do you want to use constructed
arithmetic and if so how would you
want to handle those gaps
and what do we think the default we
think should be
named things like a month turns into
just flip over the january to february
yeah so our
current existing behavior is that we
roll back so if you say
date plus of january 30th one month you
will get february 28th
but
the caveat being that
our
normalization scheme that datelist has
used forever actually rolls over
so if you say
february 30th in a date list it will
give you march 2nd instead of rolling
back to february 28th
and we currently don't really have a
system that is that is roll forward i'm
sorry what oh
what was the case where it rolls so if
you if you say date list of 2021 comma 2
comma 30 it will give you back
2021 3 comma 2. it will roll that date i
see i see the interpretation it rolls
over
okay well it's all well and good to give
a method option for date plus but what
if you just type the plus sign
right so that is
going to
our our general idea that jose and i
have discussed is basically keeping that
as it has always been which is that it
will roll backwards for those of that
arithmetic
yeah
i think we should keep it whatever
unless it's obviously broken i think
we've got to keep it the way it has been
going
right with date plus you can modify the
method with just using
expression plus then you're going to get
whatever the default behavior is
right
so two comments here one is that these
things are fundamentally in finance and
in fact some of our
financial functions already have
something like this to worry about and
the other thing is that
um in astronomical computations one
actually is interested in the physical
arithmetic
yes so that's that's one of the
motivations and this also reminds me of
your ask of your question
what is a third of a century after the
yes yes yes yes yes
right
good question right so we we should have
known this a few weeks ago
by the way fixed doesn't seem like oh
yeah you've suggested alternative names
yeah
yeah so
what about that or something
well
yeah so
so i think physical my preferred is
physical for the for the
fixed case but the other one is the
difficult one constructed is our name
so
we thought originally of calendar
but the calendar seems to suggest only
calendars and we want this to apply also
for time zones and lip seconds
well why do you have to have a name
other than roll forward but roll
backward
so
we don't need one in the method option
um but we'd want to have some way of
referring to it when we're documenting
at least i mean we can
be more explicit but
we talked about
either synthetic or
i think that's totally confusing i think
it will be
um
what about calendar defined
as opposed to
physically defined
that would be somewhat clear to me if i
saw them both together calendar defined
versus physically defined
we could use calendar it's just that we
are worried that people are not going to
assume that this works for time zones
too
oh gosh
or time systems and
we wanted to work for the three
parameters simultaneously
well calendar
i think
calendar defined is okay
i mean if it's just a description it's
not a function name
okay
and you prefer physical over fixed for
the the method name if we're just saying
it's 86 thousand 400 seconds for a day
more or exact you could do exactly
i don't like that
it's years or months are exact as well
so the calendar arithmetic is nothing
exact
yeah it's just different
well what is the right description it's
it's
it's it lands wherever it lands whatever
it's numerical
no it's it's like physical versus human
invented
it's quantity versus calendar
or
constant would be enough well you just
said it quantity versus well
that would work either quantity
is that a possibility is an alternative
to um
because we are adding we are using
quantities to do calendar arithmetic
so
no i understand but but so then
i'm suggesting the possible name there
as quantity rather than fixed
like crazy i wanted to roll over that's
crazy
it's crazy
it wouldn't be crazy if quantity plus
one month will be a date plus a quantity
of one month will use the fixed case
yeah but it doesn't that's right that
only that case would make sense to have
method quantity i think
um
sandra is commenting basically the point
is you have months that are aware of
where they are in time and months that
are fixed
sort of yes i mean that's where the
fixed term comes from but i think it's i
think that requires
look one of them
gosh how to do this
okay okay one issue is that
[Music]
name uh
are there any other and so then a method
option for date plus
the pure plus sign will use a default
what other issues are there
that's mostly it um
the set option change what the plus sign
does i don't think we should do that no
no okay yeah
um there
there's a little bit of an interplay um
there
there are some possible option
combinations that don't make sense like
date plus of
uh
the weekend you know date plus of
weekend or weekday
with method goes to fix doesn't really
make sense because
the
different day types are
[Music]
effectively implicitly artificial
you know we can't say this it there are
exactly four million seconds in a
holiday yeah i understand so so error
out in those cases yeah yeah in those
cases i think we'll air out um yeah so
it's mostly a question of what we want
to name the method and
[Music]
okay
so what is this again this is
okay this is where you land is it
calendar defined or is it
um physically defined i hate bringing
physics into this
because i think
maybe i've been studying time too much
not not in this kind of way
we don't want to call it temporal
because it's just mixing terms no no
that's horrible yeah um fixed duration
or fixed definition
duration maybe only
metal duration
well what goes with roll forwards roll
backwards don't roll at all
no roll
what's wrong with something that refers
to role
well
i i
we have two cases here the fixed and the
calendar
and then one aspect that is only
applicable to calendar is this problem
of what happens with february 30
and then is where role enters
but it it's it's a secondary thing with
respect to the first question
right the reason we don't need two
options to say
what type of arithmetic and what kind of
rolling is that rolling only applies to
calendar
arithmetic
calendar defined arithmetic well so are
you are you pushing to have something
like method arrow calendar roll
backwards
versus method arrow physical
that would be the appropriate but we
avoid naming the calendar by by
doing what nick is doing here yeah
but
we still need that word for
recommendation
and and to compare to the fixed
okay
okay
once again um
you really do you does it not bother you
to bring physics into this
i'm
not to me in the sense that
to me time is a physical thing
yeah
so it's it's a calendar that has been
invented by humans
okay let me let me just play a
relativistic moment for you
what an earth happens if you add time
okay so you're adding time
okay
let's say that you're
adding time for
jupiter
and by the time that time
has been added jupiter is in a different
place
what does that then mean
in other words with respect to some
reference frame
you see what i'm saying i mean so
how do you deal with that here
here we can't
that will be something to deal with in
in astro right now astral position will
have
ways to specify i want to do light time
corrections or i don't want light time
corrections
no i understand if you add a weak okay
so there's a
you know there's a
future colony on ganymede or something
and um you say
in
at exactly this moment
you know the the government of of x
country is changing over and and it
should change over in ganymede at the
same time
and it's going to change over in
two months
okay so at the time when you said that
ganymede was such and such a distance
away from earth
at the time when you land it's a
different distance away from earth what
do you do
well we will be able to describe that
with uh
astro functions but dates it's hopeless
we don't have enough information here to
describe that so for example even the
time systems of this discussion we had
recently about different time systems of
the sun etc they are all assuming the
slices
of the solar system are the same they
are just named differently
but there is there is no
locality
i see
okay so that's a that's a global
reference frame so to speak for the
solar system exactly certain okay
yeah
so the the the space like slices are all
the same they are just named differently
and that's the time system conversion
okay humph okay so that's anonymous
basically is what you're claiming
yeah i think it is
okay
um
right maybe the
the only well difference will be with
relativistic time in the sense that
adding one second in the core of the
earth is different than adding one
second on the surface right
well yeah that was the okay that's a
different issue right that's that
that's gravitational redshift
how is that handled in this framework
that's ultimately handled with some time
system presumably
yes
that's what tcg versus tdb something
like that
exactly yes so so
here when you add a second to one of
these uh
dates with a time system it will be a
second in that type system
okay
yeah but and you can't make the
transformation to a different times that
the
different local
location has that's a different
transformation okay fine so okay method
what
i really don't like physical because i
just think it's very um
continuous is not bad
i like continuous that that describes it
well
yeah it ties in with the rolling a bit
too and that it's
yeah yeah i agree okay
i like it right because the main
difference between calendar and this
continues is that one is by steps right
like right step of week step of the step
of second whatever
i like it continuous versus roll
backward forward roll
anything else to figure out for this
um nope i think it's that's that for
that item
good okay and um
i think
we should probably wrap for today but
this is um
oh yeah these are useful
all right but they're going to require a
longer discussion
okay um
okay good work thank you
nick now that you're
running these meetings good work
um
and uh
uh okay
until the next time
see you see you all soon thanks a lot
bye bye thanks folks on the live stream